our next guest
um makes giving back even more beautiful
zach shay aka zhc is a comic artist
known for his custom paintings on homes
and schools and hospitals to spread joy
to those who need it and he doesn't stop
there
his youtube channel has over wow 22
million subscribers his mission is
simple to make people smile check it out
this is one of the largest hospitals in
the entire world and i'm going to spend
the next 100 hours customizing it and on
top of that we also have 200 000 to help
pay patients medical bills we're going
to start off by painting this entire
hallway this area needed it so bad this
has really brightened it up
i'm going to spend the next 10 days
customizing this entire school we
actually have a lot of art supplies left
over okay how many are supplies we have
oh my goodness i've never seen so much
paint in one place in my life
welcome back
zach is fabulous
how did you become the person that you
are well i i i guess i started out just
like always wanting to be an artist and
as i started doing more art i i found
out about youtube and and i really fell
in love with the space and i found out
with youtube i could go and expand more
than just like the physical artwork i
was able to like paint a lot of things i
think we do like phones we do like cars
stuff like that and then we give them to
people so so i was able to incorporate
my art with just like just making people
happy yeah yeah pretty much i just love
that you know
the
the iteration of social media has given
a lot of people this tremendous platform
huge access to people and you know you
have so many loyal loving followers and
the fact that this is your message
that's what strikes me so much about you
is because
it's a responsibility to create that
platform and have all those followers
and if you're making giving back look
fun and fulfilling
then i just applaud you i really do zach
i'm such a fan
we all need inspiration and good
examples and yet if it's too heavy i
think we all run away from it so potent
combination to make philanthropy and art
fun it's just it's a great combination i
love what you do oh thank you so much
well we love to surprise people here on
this show as well um we love somebody we
call them drew gooders because we pun my
name with everything um and um you
agreed thankfully to do a little design
project uh for a very deserving viewer
um i'd love for you guys to meet heather
fernandez she's a mother of two from
connecticut and she is
just she's always dreamt of having a me
shed and so she was looking for
something like that please take a look
at her story
hey my name is heather i am from
connecticut raising my two boys jacob
and dylan ages 15 and 12. been married
to my husband jake for 17 years along
with my mother-in-law who lives with us
and our crazy animals i also run a hair
salon and we try really hard to get back
into our community whenever we can we
have done some drives for local animal
rescues and for breast cancer awareness
month we are trying to give back to a
local woman in our community and seeing
how we can help
i am a very busy mom wife salon owner
hairdresser i have read about me sheds
for so long
but the thought of them is overwhelming
between the cost and the designing i
wouldn't even know where to begin but to
find a place for just me to unwind
sounds incredible
drew can you help
[Music]
heather i think we can help we're also
here with youtube sensation comic artist
zach zhc
who is just one of my personal favorite
people on the planet and we're also
joined by heather fernandez a salon
owner
and a mother of two who is our amazing
drew gooder who's looking for design
advice to create maybe a special space
for herself at home as a mother i
totally relate you just want a little
zen
moment a little kids 11 chickens three
dogs two horses yeah it would be fine
that i wouldn't be mad at a space to go
away it's like living in a beautiful
circus it it is that's exactly how i
would put it so you always you've been
dreaming of a me shed but i understand
it's just the whole thought overwhelms
you you don't know where to begin a lot
i mean i run a salon so i have my tribe
of girls that work for me and then i've
got my kids and my husband so the the
time to think about that and put into it
is overwhelming
okay i think you'll never find that time
right if i can find that time then maybe
i could even no
well it doesn't exist the three of us
love design it's a big part of our lives
and we have a few little tips for you
and uh we'd like to show you actually so
if these doors can open
we can actually demonstrate oh my god
great so i just won't leave i'll stay
here
yeah i think i just found her she should
have showed you that's great i have to
give it up to zach um i really want you
to take us through the room zach and
tell us what you've done here oh yeah
it's fabulous it's so gorgeous thank you
um so as you can see i went with a black
pink design on the walls um it it's like
nice and flowy and we went with
a white couch over here and then we have
pretty little colored pillows for
a bit of contrast and andrew was telling
me she she picked out the black carpet
oh i did because you we live in the east
coast and there is weather and seasons
and this hides everything exactly you've
got to have it grounds the room a dark
floor but if you have a dark floor it's
best to keep the rest of the room light
because it can soak up the light so you
want to balance that
which zac you did so beautifully here so
nice and i love the the wall sconces i'm
so into gold lately with the white it's
so pretty you know what you give so much
back to your community you're always
taking care of other people so obviously
we just want you to know
that we made this space for you and
you're gonna get everything in this room
and zach actually created a customized
um canvas painting for you as well oh
yeah you did
[Applause]
it's right over here i present to you a
one-of-one
[Applause]
gonna go home with the piece at home
with everything here today um but
obviously there's still the me shed
factor um but you know what if you take
a look at the screen actually right
there yeah um okay so that's um that's
my house yep
oh my
[Applause]
oh
god
thank you
you're so welcome don't cry in your
shirt
and don't cry over the shoulder no one
would see me no that's really sweet
thank you that is adorable
you take care of so many people and
you're because they want to though i
love that why i wouldn't change that for
anything
actually i'd love to ask you and zach
what is one tip that we could take away
and maybe apply to our day or our week
or our month heather what's something
anybody can do you just know that you
don't know what anybody's got going on
and
the little
tiny minuscule things that i know i do
for someone is not
to make any grand difference but i know
to them it means the world so it's just
the little things just be kind just
just do the little things for somebody
that's it
that's it
what's
a word of wisdom for you not just your
22 million followers but all of us in
this room i'd love to learn a tip um i
feel like just encourage people to do
what they really love and use their
passion uh and and find a way to do some
good out of it kind of like what you do
with your show you give back a lot you
love what you're doing uh you help a lot
of people it's a win-win oh my
well god really want to say thank you to
jersey shore shed builders because they
are the angels that made this me shed
possible so my heart just goes out to
thank you for doing this with us and for
heather i can't think of anyone more
deserving zack thank you for designing
this space this segment's called
designed by drew but honestly this is a
design by zach all the way
so thank
[Applause]
you thank you i mean instant influencer
returns this october and is available to
stream on youtube with its 22 million
followers thank you for the example you
set zach
[Music]
you